I was thinking about you today Ed
because I was thinking about the amazing
absolutely how you made yourself I was
thinking about it today which you know
there are artists out there who are very
talented who who are discovered but you
as you were talking about earlier you
got this guitar you're getting on the
tube you're you're going all over town
you really were a getting yourself known
on YouTube and when you got your first
hit it wasn't this you weren't this
produced act that had gone through the
machine which I think is fascinating
well I didn't make it on my looks
I disagree thank you I disagree cuz I
feel like I'm looking in a mirror
uh man I've ever seen do you know when I
when I moved to London uh you know I
played guitar at school and I wrote
songs at school and I moved to London
and I quickly realized that I wasn't any
good and everyone that I was G I was 17
I was gigging with like 24 year olds
that had good songs they sung well they
played guitar but I realized that I
could outwork them I was like I'm not
better than you but I can do more shows
I can I can go and I would book like
three shows on a Thursday night and get
on the tube and go and play three songs
three songs three songs and I was just
like if I play every night of the week
maybe two times a night maybe three
times a night and I'm just doing that
every day eventually I'll get really
good and that is what happened after a
while it just you you the practice does
make perfect where do you think that
work ethic came from I mean because I do
think that sometimes you don't even know
where it comes from you just have this
sense I think my dad my dad was really
tough on us when we were kids to work
really hard and I was always confused
because I was like but I don't like
maths I don't like science and like why
would I work at something that I don't
want to do and as soon as I found music
I was like ah I'm going to do this every
day and it was the the detriment of like
my uh academic nness like I'm I wouldn't
say I'm a hugely smart person in
academics but as soon as I found music I
was like this is what I'm going to do um
and my dad always said like choose
someone that you admire and work harder
than them so like my hero when I was as
a kid was James Blunt and when I signed
to Atlantic Records he was on Atlantic
Records and I said in his Peak year get
me his diary and we'll do double
everything that he did and that's
exactly what we did we just chose all
the things and then doubled it that's
Absol I mean and that first of all I was
talking to you backstage uh got past
your security and
uh how did he get in here um but I one
of the things that really uh blew me
away as you were you were talking to me
about how still today you spend most of
your time in studio I mean you're with
your family obviously but then you're in
the studio a lot yeah I mean out I don't
have hobbies so my hobby is music I do
two gigs a weekend and I do five days in
studio every week I do 10 10 a.m. to
5:00 p.m. every day and then that means
I can do morning routine with the kids
take them to Nursery go to Studio get
them back from Nursery put them to bed
it's like it's a nice routine to be in
do you find that there's um sometimes
people talk about this great inspiration
they sit down and Elton John will say
that sometimes these songs came to him
and he sat down and he said the good
ones came very quickly totally sometimes
you have to write a lot of ones to
get the good ones though I find I find
that like I my thing I always say so we
I'm in every day in the studio and if I
get one song a month that's good I'm so
happy because that's that's an album in
a year that's 12 songs uh in a year so
we would make like today I've I've been
in we made three songs and like maybe
one of them is good but by the end of
the week we'll have
like maybe one that's good but if I get
one this month I'm happy there's an old
saying that uh or an old concept that
when someone writes their great novel uh
and it's their amazing novel it means
they have nine ones in the drawer yeah
yeah totally and and so usually their
second novel isn't great because it was
one of the ones in the drawer that they
just handed to the publisher when they
were then a big deal that's what someone
at my record label said to me when I put
out my first record and I was like I
think I could put out my second quite
quickly and he's like don't use the
offshoots of album one go back in and
make an album and it was great advice so
I I treat every album as if it's like my
debut going in to make the thing that
you're going to give to the world first
and then you work it as if it's your
debut as as as well this album's a
little bit different though because this
was not that it's very much something
that
I I can't I was saying it to you in the
dressing room it sort of happened by
accident it was very much you because
you came out with uh an album quite
recently yeah and then you follow it up
with this uh album and I was listening
it to to today and I really love it and
you said yeah it actually it was sort of
forming while the other album was
forming which kind of blew my mind yeah
so I had this idea well I say I had this
idea my dad has my dad's full of great
ideas sometimes not so great but he his
his idea he said said to me like there's
this composer called Elgar and Elgar did
this thing called Enigma Variations
which is 14 uh compositions about 14 of
his friends and he never told anyone who
who it was about and it was an enigma
and he said there's never been a modern
version of it wouldn't it be cool if you
did a variations record so I was like oh
that's fascinating actually and I was
talking to Aaron who I made the record
with and I was like we should do this
record base it around a season and it'll
be variations of the season with with
with my friend friends uh and whilst we
were making the record I had my best
friend die my wife got diagnosed with a
tumor and then I went into a court case
and I wrote loads of songs about that in
the space of that month and then because
all of those songs were finished quite
quickly that album was done which has
became subtract but actually we were in
making variations so after all of that
we went back and finished it and it was
done but like songs like on if you know
my album sub track like the opening two
songs were meant to be on Autumn
variations they were meant to be the
first two of a and variations and it
just came they the two Sonics are very
different one's quite a sad album and
one's quite a sort of hopeful joyous
fall album and you think of autumn
variations as being more hopeful I think
so there's a lot there's a lot more like
subtract is pretty much all just Doom
and Gloom and depression and you know
being sad about we were going through a
lot
of there wasn't much happy moments um
but yeah all very I mean it's about my
friends so it's my friends like falling
in love in September or like breaking up
in September or being depressed in
September or no one turning up to their
birthday party cuz they're having a
sober September you know like it's
different it's it's about uh it's all
about September
well no cuz the thing is like I find it
I find it weird talking to Americans
about I mean you call it fall but like
England September's great everywhere but
England is in November like autumn
in England is not fun whereas you guys
it's all fall and it's apple juice and
everyone's having a great time it's not
here in Los Angeles it's oh yeah Los
Angeles it's just a different kind of
fire zero Seas um it's uh yeah so I I
think you know it gets very you know
days are really short gets very dark
very cold very lonely and it's so that's
kind of what was the inspiration of the
record that after a month of uh no so
like three months of Summer where you're
having all the fun with all the friends
and you're going to festivals and you're
get out and you're in Pub Gardens like
it suddenly changes very quickly in in
England which is sort of the inspiration
of the record but it's all like it's
weird the the changes that happened in
people's lives like I would have people
like having babies and suddenly their
life is completely shifted or getting
into a new relationship and it's
completely shifted and it's interesting
that after summer there is a switch in
people's heads that goes right back to
work back to school but it's it's a
different feeling well it's funny
because we're all on that schedule when
we're kids and then of course it changes
because you got to work through the
summer you got to work into the fall but
I still feel that way I still feel like
well time to get back at it even though
it's the same in the two times that it
happens in the year uh September and and
January those are the two where you're
like okay so I was listening to autum
variations today and there was a there
was a song you wrote about England and
you talk about how we get a bad England
gets how much you love England but we
get a r bad reputation because of the
weather and what's so interesting to me
is that and you talk about how you
actually like that weather I I think
because of my genetic Boston but also
100% Irish and everything I just love
I love it when it's rainy and foggy and
everyone else is bitching I'm in I'm I
love it I'm just so happy I would choose
like genuinely I would choose the
English Coastline any time of the year
over any other Coastline in the world
even if it's like pissing it down with
rain and it's like I love swimming in
the English sea as well it's just cold
it's like just stupid no come
on no really the English sea I don't I
mean it it's it's got to be well
actually no you're in the Gulf Stream So
it's not freezing cold it's C it's cold
yeah try to give you an out there I shot
I have a a music so my my whole last
record I made but that song in England I
wrote by the Sea and I made sub Tred by
the Sea so I was like oh I'm going to
shoot all the videos and one the
director had this idea of like you
should be in the sea and the wav should
just be like battering you down I was
like cool and she was like we could
shoot it in Los Angeles you know and I
was like no I'll do it in England and we
shot it in December and oh God I
definitely like I lost a couple of
inches for a couple of days know what I
mean I know exactly what you're talking
about
Ed at least yours came
back they're still looking for
mine